simon's institute workshop on sampling
algorithms and geometries on
distributions
so today is our last day of the workshop
i hope you have enjoyed this workshop in
the past week
we will have three speakers in this
morning's section
our first speaker is professor jonathan
matingly
he is a professor of mathematics at duke
university so as we all know he has done
a lot of amazing work in stochastic
analysis and something and many of us
have used
the result from his paper
so including myself so today he's going
to talk about mcmc for quantifying and
jury mandarin
so johnson the floor is yours
okay so thank you very much for this
invitation i really appreciate it i'm
i'm sad that i haven't been able to be
there
um and and because of scheduling issues
on my end i've had to watch the talks
i've been able to see asynchronously but
i've enjoyed them but i also that means
that i was a little nervous after
watching some of the talks because
um
although i usually give the theory talks
at conferences this is not a theory talk
at all
this is uh this is kind of this is a
talk that in is inspiring me to think
more about interesting theory that i
haven't thought about before
because there's nothing like a really
good application to force you to to to
actually discover that things you
thought were obvious and worked well
sometimes don't work well at all in
practice
so let me uh let me go ahead and just
get to it
so uh what i want to talk to you about
is an application an application that i
think is interesting because i think
it's it's harder
than
sampling the izing model but it's easier
than sam than doing protein folding so
maybe it's an interesting example for
some people to think about
all right so let me give you a little
bit of the background so it's it's this
problem with american democracy
right now across the country um the
census is going the census data has been
released to the states and they're in
the process of taking these these census
data and drawing new districts so every
states divide up into districts whether
it's for their state legislature or
whether it's for the congressional so in
this case it's i'm talking about north
carolina's congressional seats so and
these districts are used to elect people
for congress for instance and so they
take the vote of the people
and translate it into election results
and what's it may be more surprising
very interesting is the exact structure
of those districts are incredibly
important
for the outcome of elections all right
so
you know in some ways i think of the
vote is people's will be expressed and
then how those votes lead to people
being elected is how we interpret that
vote and what i want to tell you is that
you can take the same set of votes
and elect three people from one party
and whatever it is ten people from the
other
so you can take the same set of votes
and if you use a different set of maps
you get completely different election
outcomes all right so somehow the
how the maps are drawn are the absolute
most important part in many ways of
interpreting the votes of of the people
so
so you know here's some let me try and
get my the zoom
out of the way so i can see my slides
there we go
so different maps
you get very diverse and just
results even though they're using the
same election votes so that leads to a
question about which map should we use
all right so there we go so and this is
often referred to as gerrymandering
which is this idea that you can
manipulate or change the outcome of an
election
by
changing the boundaries of the districts
all right and here's an old picture it's
a very old problem in american democracy
it goes back to the 1812.
and so
this
leads to the question which is often
asked well what would happen if there
were no political agendas all right
and implicit in this discussion is our
idea of comparing to what should have
happened or what would have happened
all right so what we want to discover is
we want to discover how the rules and
policies interact with the political
geography of a state and what i mean by
political geography of the state is the
shape of the state where the people live
where people of different parties live
these are all kind of and it's not just
parties it's you know different
socioeconomic groups different racial
groups different you know
different
different where people you know what
what types of jobs people have different
different uh
different uh
different vocations right where they all
live
and so we want to understand how they
interact and to create this translation
from votes to election outcomes all
right so
here's
three four historical maps from north
carolina three of them were used in
actual elections and one of them was
drawn by a set of judges who were
retired who wanted to see what would
happen if could they make better maps
there's half republicans have democrats
and um you know you might want to ask
well how can i compare and contrast
these three maps you might just look at
them but what i'm going to try to
convince you of briefly although mainly
i'm going to talk about sampling here
is that if you pick just draw maps by if
you just judge math by how they look
you'll be misled so here are those same
four maps
and one way to compare them is to have a
bunch of other maps so here's a bunch of
other maps that you can compare them to
and what you might want to ask is how
does the property of these maps you know
now i've made even more maps and i've
kind of gone ahead and labeled as an
ensemble of maps so we want to generate
an ensemble of maps and compare
how
those maps compare to the maps we're
interested in
and just to kind of give you a little
bit of motivation i'll tell you that the
work that i'm going to talk about much
of it has been used in these court cases
in fact and it's not just my work it's
other people's work there's lots of
people who've gotten involved in this
um we were doing some of it at the very
beginning and now there's a great number
of people working in this
and one of the reasons unfortunately
i've been watching this conference which
the talks i've seen have been very
interesting asynchronously is because i
i a conference i was involved in was
moved unfortunately to conflict with
this conference
and um that i was organizing and it it's
it's unusual this was a conference
sponsored by if you look down here
the the public policy school the law
school the
all these different entities and the
math department which is maybe unusual
and that's because in the middle of it
one of the headlining set of talks was a
bunch of talks about using quantitative
methods in redistricting so this is
really something that the practitioners
are really interested in
all right so let me tell you
where i'm going to go where this is
going to go so
in the beginning there's kind of three
steps i think of this the first one is
how do you define a distribution so i'm
going to define a probability
distribution right a a distribution on
the space of all possible redistrictings
of the state of north korea you can
think of that if i think about north
carolina being made up of precincts and
the adjacency graph gives me a graph on
those precincts
so there's about 3 000 precincts i have
an adjacency graph on that which is a
planar 2d graph typically
but not always but you can just pretend
it is and then i want to encode
a distribution on partitions of that
graph into the number of districts i
have so north carolina right now would
be 14 districts for like for the state
for the congressional delegation and i
want to encode the law
the policy
into some energy function into some
score function which will i'll use as a
gibbs measure and then i'm going to
second step is i want to build an
ensemble which just means i want to
sample algorithmically draw from that
distribution
right and there's lots of different ways
people are thinking about this
sequential markov chain monte carlo uh
enumeration for small ones and markov
chain monte carlo which is what i'm
going to talk about today but then if i
had more time if you gave me another
hour i could then talk about number
three a lot which is actually a
fantastically interesting kind of field
of scientific communication of how do
you explain these ideas and how do you
transmit them to the courts and to
policymakers in a way that they can find
digestible and useful
all right so i'll say a little bit about
that at the end
all right so
by the way please i can't actually see
you guys right now it's that always the
problem on zoom because unfortunately
usually i like to have my other ipad up
and running but it's not running for
some reason at the moment hey jonathan
so i have a question so why do you use
sampling instead of optimization
because
um the goal is not to optimize and find
first of all it has to be a political
conversation okay
so it's not like there's a computer
that's gonna spit out a set of maps and
they're gonna use these maps so i'm not
i'm not in this conversation although
this separate conversation i'm not
thinking of using this as a way to
produce the map we use i'm thinking this
is a way to compare whether the map they
pick is in the neighborhood in the kind
of
realm of reasonable maps given what they
care about so i'm gonna instead of doing
it's the same reason you do bayesian
statistics instead of just picking
picking the maximum likelihood i'm
interested in the actual distribution of
maps
that are would be allowable and not just
the one that minimizes some functional
okay
right so you should really think of this
as kind of a sampling problem that would
be akin to thinking of kind of sampling
from a likelihood in some bayesian
beijing sampling problem all right
so there's those three steps did i
answer the question well enough yeah
and now i'm going to define some
probability distribution so i'm going to
give some score function and define some
gibbs measure here and that score
function i'm going to take what a
reasonable thing is just a sum of the
independent factors that kind of they're
not really independent because they
influence each other but you think of
them independently and of course by
adding them like this i'm taking in some
sense the the maximal entropy measure
within the constraints of these these
observables that i have here so
population
some idea of compactness people don't
want counties to be split or they don't
want cities to be split and they maybe
want
depending on where you are compliance
with the voting rights act for minority
representation so for compactness we
often take isoparametric scores
we often just take l2 population
deviation from some ideal population and
then there's other kinds of ideas around
communities of interest or affinity
scores
where you're in california i'm not but
if you're in california right now
there's a real lot of talk in michigan
and california about communities of
interests
and and then the voting rights act so
all of these things kind of i'm not
going to talk about how we encode them
mathematically but here's some ideas
and we create some some some score
function okay some some energy function
if you will some likelihood some log
likelihood uh function that's going to
use to be kind of saying how good is
this map at satisfying our criteria
um so okay here was a little bit about
municipal scores but i'm not gonna talk
about that here so okay so then what i'm
gonna typically do is use a version you
know just use vanilla metropolis
hastings
um
so we all everyone here i think knows
metropolis hastings so i'm going to do
some type of exception rejection and q
here is my proposal chain so i'm going
to have some markov chain and so c is a
coloring of my graph
and i'm going to propose moving from one
coloring to another coloring and then
i'm going to do the standard kind of
rejection stuff all right and one of the
reasons i'm putting up here is just to
remind you
that if you're not having if you don't
have a reversible rejection you need to
be able to calculate forward
probabilities and backwards
probabilities all right
and here i just have just the vanilla
metropolis hastings not you know with
the standard kind of
uh
except projection scheme so there should
be a min one here i forgot to say that
um all right and of course the reason we
picked this is it gives local detail
balance when we're in equilibrium so it
fluxes across the boundaries and we'll
come up we'll talk a little bit about
that in a second
all right so there are basically two
basic types of proposals that are
usually used so of course metropolis
hastings has two parts the energy and
then the proposal i mean the proposal
and then the energy function so the
first one is just what you might call
single mode flip which is like an
ising-like move which is the first thing
anyone would try and then the second one
is a much smarter global move which is
is kind of a recom or merge split move
which i'll talk about all right so
here's the simple
ising move which is how we started off
so here's iowa actually divide into four
districts so each of these little dots
is a precinct
and the colors represent different
congressional districts
and you might take
look at the interface where edges that
are between two different colors the
conflicted edges if you will that don't
agree in their colorings
you pick one of them at random or maybe
you do some kind of gibbs probability
you pick some kind of heat bath like a
global dynamics and you pick one
according to that you pick one and then
you pick a direction to shift the color
across that's the easiest thing you
could do and that works okay but it's
not great
a better idea was the idea that the
duchenne
deformed
and solomon came up with which was
each of these uh partitions induces a
small sub-graph so here's a part of
north carolina so i have it divided into
three districts and they do some
sub-graph i could pick two of them
according to some rule maybe at random
and merge the green district and the
orange district i'm assuming you can see
my pointer if you can't please yell
and then merge them into a new district
and then draw a spanning tree right we
have good algorithms like rupert's
random walk to draw minimal spanning
trees
i mean you draw a uniform spanning tree
or you could
use minimal span trees but that's a
different conversation but
so right now i'm thinking of using like
wilson's algorithm blueprints random
walk to draw a uniform spanning tree
and then since one of the most important
criteria here are balanced populations
so we want to draw a balanced partitions
so what we can do is we can walk across
the tree walking across the trees a nice
order end criteria
our operation so we can walk across this
tree and find an edge that we could cut
and maybe find all the edges and pick
one of them at random whoops sorry
and cut this red edge here where my
mouse is and then we end up with two new
partitions all right and repeat this so
that was the idea of this recon now the
problem with that is
is that no one
we don't know what it samples from
actually
there's some strong evidence it's pretty
close to uniform on
spanning force
of these partitions but it's not we
don't know that for sure yet
and uh and and the other problem is you
can't metropolize this very well because
calculating the reverse direction of
these arrows is very expensive as i'll
tell you in a second
so
and i want to emphasize right now so we
don't i don't actually really want to
use either of these algorithms now some
people do use these algorithms i think
it's the wrong thing to do
you know we and from the very beginning
we've emphasized that we always want to
have be sampling from a gibbs measure so
we always want to use some rejection
scheme to really be sampling we want to
metropolize to be something from a
measure that we can design that can
follow the policy considerations and one
of the reasons for that is that
the decision the discussion about
choosing this measure actually really
sharpens the conversations around policy
and i think makes things clearer
all right
so what we want to do is we want to be
able to so here i'm merging some i'm
doing the same thing before but i want
to be able to calculate the forward and
the backward probabilities this orange
error
so that i can metropolize all right i
just want to emphasize that so now let
me propose a variation
which is kind of metropolis forest recon
so before we really thought of these as
partitions and we actually have a
variation on this where we still do but
i think it's easier to explain this
first as a spanning forest algorithm so
instead let's actually keep track of the
tree structure
so now when i merge these two we're
going to again end up with this merge
district which i'm going to again draw a
uniform spanning tree
and then i'm going to split it and now
i'm going to end up with two spanning
trees now that sounds like a subtle
almost
imperceivable change but the important
thing is is that okay i have this
probability but i also can then
calculate the backwards probability
because now again i'm starting from a
spanning force i can actually calculate
the chance of drawing this spanning
force and then moving backwards to and
then cutting it to end up with these two
spanning force induced on the partitions
right
so
so the point is we really need to be
able to calculate both the forward
probabilities the black arrows and the
backward properties and so here let me
try to
uh let me actually before i do that this
this slide i wish was in a different
place but i guess i left it here so i'll
just deal with that for a second
um
when we do this we kind of we're
switching from thinking about partitions
to spanning force and in doing so
um we we we this tau is the number of
spanning force on a partition we
introduce a parameter gamma which we're
going to use to kind of move our measure
forgetting about the effect of j so if j
was zero for a second
when gamma is uh at zero this is going
to be uniform on spanning force and when
gamma equals one it's going to be
uniform on partitions and we're really
interested in spending sampling from
partitions because that makes the most
sense from the policy point of view but
but it's actually this algorithm
naturally samples on on spanning forests
and that's gonna be a problem we're
gonna have to get around
and so so this is the mathieus slide i
have here
so i'll just tell you the problem is
is that if you see so we we start off
with if we think about starting off with
a partition we start off with a
partition
then we merge two of the partitions and
that's a mini to one map like there are
many partitions when merged create the
same big partition
and then
we pick a random spanning tree on that
and that's a one to many random map
and then we split it in a way that keeps
it relatively balanced into two trees
expanding four trees on each that
induces a new partition and that's a few
to many and then if we erase them and
collapse back to partition that's a mini
to one
and the problem is is that what we
really want to be able to do is invert
this map and go backwards and this red
step is really expensive to invert where
if we just stopped a moment earlier if
we just went from trees to trees we
wouldn't do this last collapse and then
it actually it's like it's like um
augmenting our state space when you do
kind of bayesian sampling and you want
to augment the state space to make
sampling better so we're going to keep
track of extra information that we're
not actually interested in but by in
what by kind of
by lifting our property measure up to
spending for us we get a
algorithm that is much more feasible
okay
okay so that that's great but the
problem is
is that we often want to preserve
entities like counties in a way that is
hard to do even with the score function
and more to the fact we often sometimes
need to be able to go down to much
smaller geographic entities so in north
carolina there's about 3 000 precincts
if i started introducing sp um census
blocks which is a smaller block and i
got rid of ones that are ridiculous i'd
still be left with something between
around 80 to 100 000 census blocks
and maybe i could cull and merge them
together but still that's a lot more and
the problem is if this algorithm drawing
these fan trees becomes quite expensive
relatively speaking especially and then
doing this reversible stuff becomes
expensive
so what we've done the next was we
developed a multi-scale
algorithm for for expanding for sampling
these partitions which i hope you'll
find interesting
so what we're going to think now instead
is we're going to first so here i have a
a tree a spanning a a tree on this space
where i've represented in kind of a
multi-scale way so i both have
these these biggest blocks are counties
and then i have precincts which are
these smaller blocks if you can see my
mouse and then right here in some of
these areas it gets even smaller and
those are our even smaller regions so
let's what we might do first so
is draw we merge two regions so draw the
dark take the dark gray and the green
and merge them into a place into one one
one one sub graph at the county level
and then draw a spanning tree which is
very inexpensive because there's not a
lot of counties here
and then pick a place to split it and
then once we pick a place to split it
we then resolve our graph only in that
one area so now we draw spanning force
on the smaller graph
stipulating these where these cuts are
essentially and then we find places to
cut that and we could continually
iterate this down to like you know we
have code that does multi-scale
drawing these multi-scale objects which
is an interesting point of view i think
all right and that of course makes
things much cheaper because the
expensive things here are like running
wilson's algorithm and calculating the
determinants to calculate the number of
spanning trees on these spaces so so you
know these are somewhere between high
and square n squared plus height delta
just just shy of n cubed algorithms so
we want to be able to you know having
this logarithmic partitioning of our
scales gives us much better um much
better algorithms
all right so here i can't not show you a
movie
so here's a whoops here's a movie should
start let's see if we'll start now there
it goes so here's this algorithm running
at a couple of different scales and
you'll see it periodically kind of
resolve different regions and not
resolve other regions as it moves around
and it's running pretty this is of
course a movie this is in real time but
it's not so bad it's it does a pretty
good job now of course this is just our
proposal so we have this multi-scale
proposal then it's actually a bit tricky
to to keep track of forward and backward
problem probabilities across this
hierarchy but we can do it by
introducing some ideas about marked
edges
and keeping track of some data
structures to keep track of some
interesting some of the data so that
things run more efficiently we can turn
unpack some algorithms some steps into
constant cluster 01 cost i mean on cost
all right so let me come back to this so
let's see how am i doing on time yeah
i'm doing kind of okay not great but
okay so
um
so let me go back to this so you know we
have this energy this function here and
i and i wrote it this way and i'm really
writing as a partition as an energy a
gibbs measure against the base measure
of uniform sampling of partitions
if i'm now interested in doing something
on a spanning tree so i need to
introduce this weight here and a
parameter gamma
which which
kind of interpolates between uniform on
spanning trees when gamma is zero
and uniform on partitions when gamma
equals one
and that's what these two are although i
think i have a typo here maybe
um
and the reason it's important is that if
you
if you're uniform on partitions you end
up with and so what this is is this is a
a kind of a simulated state where we
have a city in the middle
and so the thing about cities is that
they have lots of edges from a few small
city precincts to big county precincts
around them
and what what's what what these two are
is one of them is where we sample to the
the the width of each edge gives how
often
that edge was on the boundary between
some districts so i think we split this
into three different districts
and or five districts either three or
five i can't remember anymore and and
all i really want you to notice is if i
sample on partition space or tree space
my cuts come in different places right
there's this red is the difference
between them and so if you don't want to
introduce some biases between how cities
and rural areas interact
biases that weren't explicit in your
measure your gibbs measure your cost
function j you have to be careful
so we really want to sample from
partitions because we think that that's
the right policy driven measure
and so we need to think about how
and and i'll just tell you that when we
sample on partition space our markov
chain is very poorly mixing and when we
sample on tree space it's very good
mixing okay
so
here's a bigger picture of the same ones
kind of blown up i'm just i i'm kind of
giving you at a cartoon level just to
motivate what's coming next so what
we've what we've done and other people
for a while have done is we've looked at
various ideas of parallel tempering and
simulated tempering so in other words
we're going to run chains at different
you know one of them at the bottom is
going to be driven is going to be on is
better mixing in a mathematically
convenient distribution this time on
tree space
and then here we're going to have a
worse mixing policy driven distribution
which will have more compact districts
will have beyond partition space
and we're gonna do this standard
parallel tempering algorithm that's to
say we're gonna we're gonna have walkers
a different this is actually more
simulated tempering if you will so
you're walking on one temperature and
then you periodically jump up and you
walk there and you jump up and you move
around but you can also do parallel
tempering where you have chains running
at each temperature now
one thing that we've had and i'd be
curious to hear other people who have
experienced giving me ideas but one so
and here's some different chains as
they're switching between different
values of beta if you will these gamma
levels
and so these are what gamma index
they're on somewhere between the zero
and one gamma equals zero is
trees and partitions and these are
different these are different threads in
a in a multi-core
version of this multi-threaded version
of this
algorithm and so we're walking up and
down
um and by swapping chains when you do
that you want the swap probability to be
pretty good and in a way rather uniform
across the state space so you want to
make these changes in your tempering
parameter be very small but sometimes we
would need to do as many as 400
different temperatures
in this problem even though it's you
know not as bad as you know something
like like uh protein folding
and of course 400 temperatures either
means i need a lot of compute power on
on you know on on
on the amazon cloud or the google cloud
or something like that or oak ridge has
to decide to give me a machine
or i have to use something smarter and
one of the things we're experimenting
with is kind of
since this seems to have there's a very
directionality to this we're we're doing
smaller chunks of parallel tempering
where we kind of build up a good
sampling of our measure and then use
that as a heat bath almost
to to feed plans at a lower gamma into
the higher gamma's
uh parallel tempering chains and so we
can do that in a way that still
preserves measure and that's so that's
been
you know this is pretty fresh work and
it seems to be working pretty well but
we're making progress
all right
so
um so now i have way too many slides on
the next topic so i'm going to skip some
of them as i go through but another
thing we tried at one point was to
replace metropolis hastings with
something else
and there's some nice ideas that other
people have had like sequential monte
carlo seems to be working it's a little
bit related to the parallel tempering in
a way um but another thing you could try
to do with to try to do non-reversible
markov chain monte carlo
so you know the classic example that
goes back to neil holmes and and
diaconus in the math literature for sure
and and you know various other people in
the physics literature is the idea
instead of replacing diffusive random
walks which is essentially what sampling
is with some type of ballistic stirring
so right if you know if you're just
going to sample these nodes uniformly if
you do random walk you're going to need
n squared to cover just to typically
cover everything
here if you just ballistically run
around it you're going to only need
order n right to sample every vertice of
this graph
and the idea of lifting is you still run
a metropolize scheme
but you
make this move on the left out of two
ballistic moves and whenever you have a
rejection instead of just sitting still
you switch whether your momentum is
taking you in the plus direction in the
minus direction so in some ways this is
a a version of kind of a longitude
you're giving your chain momentum so
it's a large event a discretized
momentum version all right and as i said
here's some references
so um
so we had two different versions of this
one where we actually you know went back
to the stirring your coffee analogy
since we're in the plane we actually put
a vector field on this and we tried to
stir the center of masses of our
districts the centroids our districts
around according to flow but we also had
another version where we where we just
tried to have different momentum just
decide whether the green was flowing
into the purple or the purple is flowing
into the green at the moment and and and
and had a whole graph of momentums
between
all of the different uh
districts we had all the different
colors here we'd have a different
momentum between them telling which at
this moment which way they were flowing
and so we did that and uh and uh so
here's just a little bit so the idea
would be you'd propose a move
if it was in that you only accept
consider moves that are in the direction
of your stirring if it rejects then you
flip the direction of your stirring okay
and so
it here's i'm not going to go into it
here's just an algorithm it looks a lot
like metropolis hastings but it has this
extra momentum in it
all right and so let me uh skip this and
we have so let me show you a movie here
so here's a toy example so this is one
of these the simple middle one is
tempering the one on the right is
reversible a non-reversible and the one
on the left is reversible and the thing
to notice here is that the one on the
right will eventually flip over because
we have a stirring
and the one so and the one and the two
in the middle will not do as well
so eventually this will flip over here
there it goes but this is kind of a
simple toy example which is much better
than you could ever hope
and the graph at the bottom shows a
little bit more the truth
so um actually it turned out that having
this momentum did no better
than just doing some smart tempering
in our problem that is to say instead of
uniformly picking which way to do single
node flip and do the izing move but
picking them with some tempering we did
much much better and the center of mass
still did best in a simple example but
when we got to bigger examples we
actually saw the center of mass degrade
and it's a lot more expensive so we're
not actually using this right now in our
sampling but it was interesting idea and
it led to kind of a discrete version of
oh in a way a longitudinal sampling yeah
there's a we've haven't finished writing
that up but there is a version of this
which has not not discrete plus or minus
momentums but more uh uh
continuous momentums which would be more
like the longitudinal sampling on this
space of graph partitions
all right so um
right so i mean we did see some nice
properties we saw kind of movement from
these metastable states much better and
the blue one which is the center of mass
split
but um and after you know after only 25
000 steps it had moved around a lot more
the center of mass was more equally
distributed where uh
the two districts were kind of more
split on had a certain orientation that
had to do with the initial condition but
after ten to the seven steps they both
did just as fine and it wasn't that you
know if you actually kind of comp
computer cost and algorithmic costs the
center of mouse wasn't much better
all right so uh right and that's what
this says but i don't i don't think i
have time to go into that
in huge detail all right so let me
actually there's a general
idea about subdividing your graph into
different spaces and assigning momentums
if you're interested i'm happy to talk
about that so we kind of create a
partition and we assign momentum into
different partitions of our state space
not of the graph space but of the actual
state space so this works very well
and then we have different chains
associated with different momentums we
get
you know a whole stack of different
momentum
um it's nice theory but i don't it
didn't work so well in this example
all right so okay so there's a lot of
work going on so i'm going to just
quickly mention two other ideas which
are maybe outside the topic of this
chain of this conference but i think
they're interesting to think about
so the first one was some work that
started with alan freeze and maria and
wes
and um
and and it's been used actually in a
couple court cases also and then we we
kind of had a
an extension of that i worked with them
to do an extension that and it's really
the idea about all right um
you know it measures just the fragility
of a gerrymandering but but the idea is
is that sometimes to measure whether
something is an outlier if you're not
trying to exactly sample from the
distribution you actually can use a not
a mix a chain which isn't sorry a chain
which isn't mixing so what's interesting
about this
these methods is they don't use any
they don't require any mixing guarantees
so some so it's an interesting question
it's an example of if you
know what your question is and your
question is is this thing an outlier
relative to this distribution is this
example that i have an outlier how far
in the tails is it you can actually do
something with with guarantees
that doesn't require you to
faithfully sample the whole measure it
just needs in this case it just needs a
reversible markov chain monte carlo
method so like metropolis hastings works
just great um and it really can give you
bounds and so this is something i think
is important to think about we don't
always have to have the intermediate
step sample the
distribution well for certain types of
questions you can actually don't you
don't need guarantees on your sampling
rates um another thing which has been
very interesting is to actually come up
with smart clever enumeration techniques
that prune the tree and actually
enumerate every single partition in
small cases
and uh this is some work that uh kesuke
inuma and ben fightfield really
pioneered in this area
and i'll just say that in in one of our
court cases we actually this graph to
your right here was actually
here was the purple was what we got by
our sampling methods and for this small
subpart of the problem that was actually
interesting in its own right for the
court case we were actually able to
enumerate it completely and show that
our sampling method was doing a really
good job and so uh you know we actually
presented a clever uh you know a state
of the art enumeration method in court
as a validation for a sampling method
okay so
i think i have maybe 15 minutes left so
maybe it's a good is that right about 10
minutes maybe 10 minutes left uh yeah
about 10 minutes left yeah maybe only
five actually i just remember you said
40 not 45 so no no no no no no you start
a little bit later you have 10 minutes
okay okay okay all right so um what i'm
about to go to now is to explain how
some of these ideas could be used but
i'm also happy to take so so let me let
me just take a little bit of time to
explain how we explain this to the court
and maybe show you some of the out some
of the products of this analysis
and then i'm happy to go back to the
algorithms and i know i went fast over
some of that i'm happy to talk more
about it
so um the kind of things we do
is if you look just for a second over
where my cursor is at this histogram so
we've taken some you know
tens of thousands of maps we've actually
converged them using some kind of
gilman room and statistics and looking
at the total variation distance of these
plots and some other blocks some
projected marginals to see when those
converge
and what we get is this histogram so
given a certain set of votes we got this
histogram of the number of seats for a
particular party elected and we could
compare like the map that we were given
and then a map that was eventually the
court put in and what's interesting to
note though is that
you know here's the same kind of
histograms but now in a whole bunch of
different elections so here's governor
from 2012
u.s house from 2016 presidential
election in north carolina from 2016
president 2012 senate governor all right
and they're organized in more democratic
at the bottom more democrat dominated to
more republican dominated sorry more
democrat dominate at the top and more
republican dominated in the bottom
and so as you would expect for counting
democrats elected these blue histograms
move to the right as we increase
but what's interesting is if you look at
these purple dots which are the maps
that we actually used in 2016 the
outcome almost doesn't change at all
so in some sense the people change their
opinions dramatically between these two
different sets of votes at the top and
the bottom and the outcome of the
election didn't change almost at all
where if you use some
more bipartisan drawn maps or some
random apps they actually it does change
and that's what this blue histogram
shows and so now there's a movie and
these kind of movies we show in court so
here's the statewide vote fraction
slowly ticking up here and as it does
you see the the blue histogram of our
ensemble of maps
shifts to the right
and then this map the court eventually
put in place moves with it but this
enacted map stays dramatically behind it
doesn't start moving until almost 55 so
here i'll play it one more time
it this map doesn't really start moving
until around 55 percent democratic vote
instead of north carolina which is a lot
that's not realistic outcome north
carolina is usually in the high 40s to
the low 50s
so that's so for the most of where the
election takes place this map doesn't
the the purple map doesn't have any
response to changing opinion of the
electorate
here's another similar type thing and
again the same kind of thing where
there's a whole bunch of elections
here's the line the style line that i'm
highlighting right now is where the
super majority is
here's the change of the control of the
party of the of the chamber and you see
over here where it's mostly
republican-dominated does a very good
job but it's not such a bad map the
purple dots aren't so far off from the
histograms but as the power would be in
danger of swinging to the other party
these purple mat the purple map
dramatically under reports the election
outcomes
and if you watch this movie now
um
you'll see that this overturned map that
was overturned in a court case in which
i testified will be stuck for quite a
while and in this these use these
sampling methods that i'm talking about
and and now you know you'll see that
this overturn map will will delay a long
time in crossing this dotted line which
is the super majority being broken
that's the that's the number of votes
you need to override the governor's veto
and now as this slowly shifts to the
right you'll start seeing that it will
the blue histogram and the yellow map
will shift completely giving the
democrats control the chamber long
before this purple one finally does
there it goes
and this picture down here is maybe a
little hard to explain right now but i
can explain it in a different picture
what it measures is whether there's
whether districts have an abnormally
this is where we'd expect districts to
be in the middle of these box plots and
these purple and the orange ones were
districts we actually used in elections
and what you should take out of this is
this is the amount percentage of
democrats on the y-axis
and these districts have abnormally
abnormally high numbers of democrats and
these districts have abnormally low
numbers of democrats and so what's
happened is they for political reasons
they've stuffed democrats in these
districts to take them out of these
districts and this is an effect called
packing and cracking so we can identify
such effects and explain them to the
court
and another thing that's important i
just can't help but say to everyone is
that people talk a lot about
proportionality when they talk about
elections in the united states our
elections really should have nothing to
do with proportionality and what's nice
about this ensemble methods these markov
chain monte carlo sampling methods is
that we can discover
what
the correct relationship should be given
our geography of our state and the rules
we have in place
between the votes and the number of
seats without invoking proportionality
which to be honest has nothing to do
with anything in our rel in our
elections our elections aren't designed
to create proportional outcomes right
they're designed to
make sure that
the there's some geographic distribution
of our representation
and and i'm not going to talk about this
but yeah we'll skip this and we also do
some spatial stuff to try to explain
where things are actually harmed at a
spatial level in
in our election analysis okay great
and so with that i'll just stop maybe
from you know an educational point of
view one thing that's interesting about
this is these are all my collaborators
over the years and maybe i've left
someone off now it keeps growing
but um a lot of these are undergraduates
and masters students
this type of work is really motivating
to them and it's a very kind of diverse
group in every way you can expect you
know very least of which is what their
actual major were i had political
scientists and economists and
you know every type of
engineer you can imagine as well as math
majors
um
and says stats majors and computer
scientists so
it draws in a really broad group of
people and so all these ugs are
undergrads which is interesting all
right and i should also say if you're
interested in more on this we have a
website that has a blog that explains
lots of these ideas and small little
descriptions as well as you can find
links to all of our court cases and all
of our
papers that we've posted on the archive
and so maybe with that i'll just stop
with this movie
and uh yeah sorry i should have i meant
i thought i updated this one but i seem
to have not saved the updated version so
anyway ignore my conclusions
they were for a slightly different talk
but um that's what i wanted to say so
thanks a
i'm
lot
with
any questions
yeah thank you for the great talk
yeah let's take a few
questions so i would start my training
so uh
in your experiments you showed us uh
different uh maps generated by the
something algorithms
uh developed by your team so i wonder
uh
what is the
way to refer to the good news software
for example the policy or the map you
generated because i don't see any
comparison between for example other
maps generated by
let's say human expert or some other
workers so do you have such kind of
comparison so there's two answers to
that so first of all um if you look
if you look at you know like
these maps
these blue ones here i mean these uh
these green ones are actually drawn by
human workers right
but a non-partisan group that was trying
to so we have some validation that and
you see they're pretty central to our uh
if you look there in the middle of our
box plots here if you can see them yeah
yeah it's not going to say yep oh there
it goes finally
bandwidth
so they're not so far off from the
centers of our box plots where these are
really far off so
so that's one way we do it the other way
we do it is we actually uh
we actually when we design this
this this uh
when we let me just get rid of this this
part here
when we design this energy function
right these are kind of nonpartisan
criterias we tune them
we're trying to get better about it by
using some kind of inference techniques
using some markov chain monochrome
inference techniques but we tuned
these maps to be centered
around
the values of these functions the
compactness the equal population score
that we see in historical maps
so we say even if our maps look like
your maps in these non-partisan criteria
that you say that you use
how do they look like what do they look
like in the partisan criteria and we see
that they're very different that's one
thing and you know to this audience i'll
say two things one
uh first of all i mean the theory is
pretty wide open right we don't even
know like this this randomly space
forest tree thing we don't know what it
samples from
uh there's lots of interesting places
for people to come with performance
guarantees and and these same kind of
problems can use it all different kinds
of graph partitioning algorithms we
think
where you want to you know
split into groups i had a student who
was thinking about this with some
statisticians about about dividing up
into groups that had subgroups for
experiments so that they would have the
same some certain properties you know
like kind of marginal table type
sampling problems
um
but there's also um i should also say
that there's some interesting uses of
the machine like machine learning that
people have used uh in trying to kind of
judge
do these maps look like these other maps
if you you know in nonpartisan ways
right so that's another thing people
have tried to use
to try to learn the distribution and
then learn the score function a way to
make it quicker to make these these
algorithms faster yeah
so when you say then the score function
do mean then the
coefficient is of i in front of each no
i mean the actual the whole thing this
big j
right okay so we actually pick these
score functions we but then we have to
fit the alphas
we have to fit the alphas to make it to
make it look like maps that people tend
to use okay i see i see
and you know that's that's the
interesting part i mean this is what you
know this is an interesting you know we
can run some of these parallel tempering
runs
in five or six hours right
um and so it's a hard enough problem
that
that that that you that you need good
ideas but it's easy enough that you can
actually play around with it and have
some ground truth you can actually look
at these maps right in a way you can't
look at some very high dimensional
protein folding problem maybe right
so uh so so i think it's an interesting
test problem to think about
yeah indeed
yes
so any other questions from the uh
so i i had the kind of a more general
question so you mentioned that there are
many
uh theoretical questions that arise from
from this work and we have a very
theoretical crowd here i know
one
question is
go ahead yes sorry so so one question is
uh you know if one one wanted to work on
some of these problems what would be a
good place to start and and
um even just looking for kind of uh
i don't know reasonably well-defined
questions yeah yeah okay so here's
here's a few questions okay so um
you know uh
so for instance there's no performance
guarantees for the simple if you just
run the proposed algorithm this recom
algorithm there's no performance
guarantees there right
there's no there's no as the problem
scales then how does it behave right no
one knows that
another problem is how
you know anything about how as i change
this measure
as i change this measure here
uh you know how if i think about
partitions how do these tree counts vary
given that i'm restricting the certain
types of compactness right there's some
very recently there's some work about
the fact how the isoparametric score
relates to this this kind of tree count
right
um another interesting question is here
i've been able to use i've been able to
use uniform spanning trees drawn by
wilson's algorithm but what if i want to
use like a a greedy algorithm right like
kruskal's algorithm to draw a minimal
spanning tree based on
putting weights on the edges right like
we know how to do
um how can you metropolize that
if i'm drawing my spanx trees from that
from from
from ms mst minimum spanning tree
how can i metropolize that for instance
right people don't know how to do that
at all right
um
there's also some interesting questions
about
uh
we think that these kind of plots that
i've shown right here i'll show you one
more i have two more questions then i'll
end
uh
let's see where's the plot so let me
show you right these plots here that i
have these histograms
we kind of see this these are kind of an
order statistics but they seem to follow
in a nice
fairly regularly spaced thing we don't
have any understanding of what that what
the parameters that affect that are
and
and even more to the case um
we see that if we only care about these
observables these marginals here
the chains actually mix faster than if
we care about the whole distribution it
seems
so in cases where we can enumerate the
problem
and they're still pretty big not super
big but kind of big meat small to medium
size
we see that if we wait for the entire
distribution to converge in total
duration it takes much longer than these
marginals to converge and actually these
marginals are all we care about
so is there's what about the geometry of
this phase space means that these
marginals converge faster right
um
all right so these are just the
projections of
the
the partisan makeup of the 13 districts
here
so there are 13 specific projections you
can think about here's 13 projections
that have some kind of well spacing
property they mix much quicker
projecting onto one variable from the
space than the actual chains do
why is that what about the geometry the
space makes that true right
yeah yes thank you for sharing those
very very interesting theoretical
questions
and in the intro time uh probably we
should wrap up here let's thank our
speaker johnson again for a great talk
thank you jonathan